mais ce que je voudrais simplement à
préciser vos pas moins de plaisir est
trop trop trop la parole en plus c'est
de dire que en fait dans tout ça dans ce
creuset on appelle le walkie sme et que
je distingue vraiment dû du mouvement ou
encore une fois il ya plusieurs choses
par exemple quand des théories du genre
qu'on peut bien de des théories du genre
il y en a plusieurs et plusieurs
courants d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de courants qui sont carrément
en fait en bisbille les uns avec les
autres il ya effectivement des thés
ancian parce que ce sont des cours à la
philosophie qui nous six militants je
voudrais revenir là dessus quand même
parce que on est en train en fait on en
parle sans vous parler et c'est pas un
gros mot ou un militantisme il ya des
militants 10 mhz de fin de tous les
côtés puisque en fait concrètement on
est dans une démocratie et donc
fatalement vous avez en fait des groupes
des associations des communautés qui
vont vouloir en fait
le jouer leur partition pour en fait
obtenir aussi gagnent cause du promu
politique
dans le militantisme puisqu'en fait les
tous les tous les exemples concon cité
qu'on a encore cité mise à part les p ô
noble qui se trouvent aux états unis
dans toute action militante le but c'est
ça soit est largement aussi étudié le
but c'est de pouvoir essayer de trouver
des actions ou porter des paroles qui
vont on va dire
en fait montré aux gens qui se passe
quelque chose qu'il faut en fait
défendre cette cause est d'accord pour
s'attirer l'attention en fait et
évidemment donc dans tout acte militant
quel qu'il soit je lis à quel qu'il soit
quel que soit le bord politique j'ai là
pour le coup j'ai aucun problème avec ça
il ya des risques d'abus ou de dérapages
puisque le but c'est de faire parler de
soi
[Musique]